There are some crazy ideas for spacecraft
propulsion out there, but tops among them
must be the idea to power an interstellar
craft with a black hole.
Wait it gets crazier.
The black hole is made of light.
Yes, that’s right, a black hole, which is
a region in space where the gravity is so
strong that, all together now: “not even
light can escape,” very good, can itself
be made from light.
Theoretically, of course.
The black holes you’re probably used to
are made of matter, and lots of it.
Stellar mass black holes usually form after
giant stars go supernova and leave a core
behind.
If that core is more than about three times
as massive as our entire sun, give or take
half a sun, its own gravity will crush the
entire thing down to a single point, forming
a black hole.
However, because of Einstein’s equation
E=mc2 we know that mass and energy are related.
It’s right there; energy equals mass times
the speed of light squared.
So you could use energy to bend space into
a black hole the same way nature uses mass.
You would just need an insane amount of energy
to get the equivalent of enough mass, since
the speed of light is a huge number, nearly
300,000 km/s, and the equation calls for you
to square it.
Light carries energy, so if you managed to
cram enough into a tiny space you would create
what’s called a kugelblitz, which is German
for “Ball Lightning.”
The good news is if we wanted to make a kugelblitz
we wouldn’t necessarily have to use the
equivalent of about three solar masses like
nature needs for a stellar black hole.
We could make them much smaller, say one with
the equivalent mass of two empire state buildings.
Then we would “only” need as much energy
as our entire sun puts out in 1/10th of a
second.
We could use a laser to create this low mass
kugelblitz, most likely one that shoots gamma
rays instead of visible light, since gamma
rays are the most energetic electromagnetic
waves and we’re trying to be efficient in
our ridiculousness.
If we managed to create this absurdly powerful
laser, focused it at some point in space,
and pulled the trigger, we could create a
tiny black hole, one with a radius smaller
than a proton.
A black hole this size would decay over the
course of about five years, giving off hawking
radiation as it decays, and it might be possible
to use that radiation to power a spacecraft.
I know, you’ve followed me pretty far down
the rabbit hole already, but I promise it’s
just a little farther.
A 2015 paper proposed that if we could create
a dyson sphere around our little kugelblitz
and harness the energy to propel a spacecraft,
it could accelerate up to 72% the speed of
light before the black hole sputters out.
That is of course assuming the dyson sphere
isn’t melted by the hawking radiation.
Or that the extreme heat generated from packing
an insane amount of energy into a tiny space
doesn’t cause something unpredictable to
happen.
A kugelblitz would be so hot that the math
we use the predict the laws of physics doesn’t
apply, so we can’t accurately say how it
would behave.
So black holes made from light and spacecraft
that could harness them are still purely based
in theory.
Hypothetically they could exist, but I wouldn’t
pin your dreams of interstellar travel on
them just yet.
Though, you can pin your dreams on a new cell
provider.
Visible is the new way to think about phone
service.
No stores.
No annual contracts.
No hidden fees.
Just 40 bucks a month for unlimited messages,
minutes, and data at speeds up to 5 megabits
per second.
All on Verizon’s 4G LTE Network.
When you think the future of phone service,
think Visible.
Visible is the new way to think about phone
service.
$40/mo phone service that's actually $40/mo.
Unlimited everything (including data at speeds
up to 5 Mbps).
All on Verizon's 4G LTE Network.
No hidden fees.
Ever.
When you think the future of phone service,
think Visible.
For more on Dyson Spheres, check out this
episode of Space Crafts!
And one last thing.
There is another phenomenon called ball lightning,
which is totally unrelated to a kugelblitz.
I bet that’s only confusing if you’re
german.
Thanks for watching, and I’ll see you next
time on Seeker.